Well, hello and
welcome everyone.
I'm Debbie Douglas, for
those of you that don't know,
I'm the curator of
science and technology
and the director of
collections at the MIT Museum.
And gathered with me on this
lovely day in October 2021
are the museum's four
directors, distinguished members
of our advisory board,
and my many hardworking
and talented colleagues
on the staff.
Today's session is being
videotaped for posterity
so we'd be grateful if you
would silence your phones
and be relatively quiet.
Although, we'll welcome
all bouquets and cheers
that you might be
inclined to share
with our distinguished speakers.
Today is the final program to be
held in the MIT Museum facility
at 265 Massachusetts Avenue.
I want to begin with MIT's land
use acknowledgment statement.
MIT acknowledges
Indigenous peoples
as the traditional
stewards of this land
and the enduring
relationship that
exists between them and their
traditional territories.
The land on which we sit is the
traditional unceded territory
of the Wampanoag Nation and we
acknowledge the painful history
of genocide and forced
occupation of their territory.
And we honor and respect the
many diverse Indigenous peoples
connected to this land on which
we gather from time immemorial.
It is good for us to
remember that our 50 year
relationship on this site
is only the most recent
and that the history of
this place is much older.
So we have here four people.
Some of you know them all, some
of you know one or two of them.
Warren Seamans,
Warren is the founding
director of the MIT Museum
but his tenure at
MIT predates that.
He was in the Air
Force even earlier.
The Museum of course,
his tenure with what
we call the MIT
Museum, began in 1971
and continued to his
retirement in 1996.
He was passionate about
history, arts, culture, and MIT
and he has
entrepreneurial instincts
that quickly apprehended
something that MIT in 1971
had not fully
known about itself,
and that's secretly,
at MIT loves history.
In 1994 Warren had
appointed Mary Lean
as associate director.
It was a new post, I
believe at the time.
The museum was
growing and it needed
to focus its operations,
finances, and staffing
to professionalize them.
And over nearly
three decades Mary
has built the operational
infrastructure
that has enabled the flourishing
of every single person,
program, exhibition, fundraising
effort, expansion, and more
that has been dreamed
up since her arrival.
But twice, Mary has
also served as acting
director between 1996
and 1998 and then again
between 2002 and 2005.
And Jane Pickering
was appointed in 1998
and served a four eventful
and transformative years
in the history of this
museum before departing
for Yale's Peabody Museum.
She subsequently returned
to Cambridge in 2013
as the inaugural director
of the Harvard Museums
of Science and Culture
and more recently,
in her new position
as the William
and Muriel Seabury
Howell's director
of Harvard's Peabody Museum
of Archaeology and Ethnology.
Allen Brody, who was
Philip Corey's predecessor,
the associate
provost for the Arts.
Once described John,
your arrival in 2005 not
so much as an appointment
but that rather
you had been shot
out of a cannon
into the Institute's midst.
MIT had come to
recognize and value
the achievements of
Warren, Jane, and Mary
all the more
exceptional considering
the limited finances, facility,
and staffing that they had.
But could it scale?
That was the question and
the challenge for John
who came to us as one of
the world's leading scholars
on the public
engagement of science
and from leadership positions
at prestigious posts
throughout the UK.
The question was could he
increase the visibility
and impact of the museum by two
or three orders of magnitude?
But Warren I wanted
to ask about--
begin by asking about
the museum's early years.
And I want to pause for a moment
and set the stage for all of us
here tonight and bring
you back to 1971.
When gas was $0.36
a gallon, when
Walt Disney World in Florida
had opened for the first time,
when NASA was launching
its final Apollo missions,
when the ARPANET debut, when
Ali fought Frazier, when
the Temptations sang,
"Justy My Imagination",
cigarette advertising on
TV had just been banned,
the voting age
was lowered to 18,
and Americans were
painfully divided
over virtually every
issue of consequence
from race and gender, gay
rights, the environment,
housing, education,
jobs, and most of all
the conflict in Southeast Asia.
So given all that
upheaval and discord
of that moment 50
years ago, when
plans are being made
for the October 7th 1971
inauguration of Jerome
Wiesner, the theme
of that inauguration,
of a 10 day event,
was called introspection.
Wiesner sensed that the moment
that called for reflection was,
at this moment was called for
reflection and re-dedication
of the community to the
values and ideas we all share.
There was a 10 day
celebration, they've
never done anything like this
before that featured concerts
and colloquium and
parties and exhibitions.
But today I want
to call attention
to one particular exhibition,
it's called Retrospect MIT 19--
--or excuse me 1861 to 1916.
Now the tech reports
that the exhibit
was organized by
Professor Richard
Douglas, the head of the
Department of Humanities.
So Warren I want to
have you start off
this conversation by saying
how did you get involved?
And how did this small exhibit
of photographs and drawings
from MIT first 55
years of history
turn into an accredited museum?
OK well very simply, I was in
the Department of Humanities
as the administrative officer.
And the head of department,
Richard M Douglas,
sent me a note, which is
probably here in the file,
asking me to find a few
photographs to put up
an exhibit for Jerry
Wiesner's inauguration.
So that sounds simple,
I'll just go to archives
and pick up, choose a few
photographs and put them up.
Well I went to the photographs
and was very quickly informed
that they didn't
collect photographs.
That they only collected
the official records
of the Institute and photographs
were not part of that.
So I started searching and
we started finding things
everywhere we turned around.
I need to say at
sort of the beginning
that my previous
job at MIT prior
to the Department of Humanities
was in the personnel or human
resources that we now call it.
And in that position
I was in charge
of finding, hiring,
promoting, whatever you do,
to the hourly people.
And there are a lot of
hourly people at MIT.
So I got to not only a
lot of the hourly people
but their supervisors as well.
And they for example,
one of our major
finds in getting going
was I called on my friend
Elmer Condon who was
head of the movers.
And I asked him
if he knew where--
he knew where everything was.
Everybody just gave Elmer the
stuff they wanted to get rid of
and he would find a place,
usually in this building
by the way.
And the first thing he
led me to was a room up
on the fourth floor
of this building,
that had not only William
Barton Roger's portrait,
the original one that no one
had seen for a long, long time,
but about 20 other important
portraits and busts.
And I immediately took the
portrait of William Barton
Rogers down to Howard Johnson.
And he immediately told
James Rhyne Killian,
the saint of all saints
as far as I'm concerned.
And Killian asked to
come up and for me
to bring him up here to see it.
And he said, don't
let any of this go,
we got to save the
history of the place.
So that's basically
the beginning.
So we started gathering
and physically searching
for whatever we could find.
And we filled an entire
building with it I guess.
So the museum, I mean excuse me,
that exhibit went up in October
but presumably it came down.
It was in the corridor
in building 14.
What happened next?
Well we started what became
historical collections.
And with that I
reported directly
to Howard Johnson for the
first two or three years.
I was the only person
at the institute
that reported directly to him.
And that led to a true search
going through every storeroom
at the Institute.
And this in turn led to a lot
of interest with the alumni.
We had all sorts of things that
the alumni were interested in.
Most MIT alumni would rather
talk about their history
than they would about the
latest scientific advance.
And that's true, so we started
drawing a lot of interest
from alumni.
And in our fifth
year, which would
be the fifth year of
existence, probably 76,
I invited the members of
a class at the reunion
to come up and see us.
We were still back in a
small part of the other part
of the building.
And as part of that they
were so impressed by what
they had seen, although
we didn't really
have an official
exhibits, that they
both the class of
'25 and '35 suggested
that MIT collections,
historical collections,
be given part of
their class gift.
Well this is a no, no.
And that got us the
interest of the higher-ups
and we just had to
fight from there.
I think John and
Jane particularly,
and Mary of course
is the mastermind
of keeping track of all this.
It will come as a bit of
a shock that Warren was
forbidden from raising money.
I thought it was compulsory.
[LAUGHING]
On that front, Warren,
in the early years
you had a really intense service
mentality of doing exhibits
for anyone and everyone who
asked, from the corridors
at MIT to, I read in
the president's report
that you even took very early
on a trip to the Florida
to the Kennedy Space
Center and represented
MIT and the
historical collections
to a couple of 100,000
people who visited.
Tell us a little bit about how
you cultivated that service
ethos and some of the early team
members who worked with you.
As far as the audience, well,
if I get the question correctly,
I started at the request
of the Alumni Association
to tour [? MIC ?] clubs
around the country.
And I think I hit every club in
Florida at least three times,
and there's a lot
of clubs in Florida.
I hit everywhere from
St. Paul, Minneapolis--
Minneapolis, St.
Paul, to Montana,
to actually some in New England.
So the word spread through
that group that we existed
and that helped as well.
So I was invited to
do a lot of things
that helped spread the word.
And I should indicate that
there was a tremendous--
by this time--
I should say at the
beginning that we
had no budget, none whatsoever.
And our main workforce was
Northeastern work study
students.
And we owe Northeastern
a tremendous amount
because we didn't
pay them anything.
And we continued to have
work study students,
even after we could finally
start to hire MIT students.
But then we were able to hire
some staff such as Barbara
Linden who came from the
archives, was a mainstay.
We had Michael Yates who had
been work-study student who
became a regular staff member.
We built up a very, very
good and talented staff
of people who were
really dedicated
and could see a future
in what we were doing.
So one of your
pivotal acquisitions
came in '93 when you bought
the holography collection.
And that's from the
Museum of Holography
and that's about the time Mary,
you and Jane came on board.
And I wondered if we might
ask you some questions
about the mid 1990s.
Mary, maybe you can reflect
on those first years.
And really here's
the burning question,
is it true that MIT wanted
to get rid of the museum
or thought about getting rid
of the museum in the mid 90s?
Well I remember Joe
Moses, who was the provost
to challenge us about what
is the purpose of the museum
and does it serve
at MIT students.
So we had to document that.
I mean, we did then, we do now.
We're a resource for students
and faculty and classes
and providing materials,
original materials,
for their work.
And I think we also
made the case for how
the museum serves the public.
But yes Debbie, we were
challenged by the provost.
So Jane, you come in.
What were your first
impressions of this place?
I mean you come from
England.
[LAUGHING]
I mean--
There's a bit of
a conspiracy here.
[LAUGHING]
Apparently.
In case you hadn't noticed.
So yeah, I was
thinking about that
because that was a
question that was
asked when I was interviewed.
Like why should
MIT have a museum?
And I remember thinking
that in some ways,
I mean you always get that
question in a University
museum, right?
You're always being asked
about service to the University
you know like versus service
to the wider community.
And hopefully the two
actually are the same thing.
But I remember thinking that
the MIT Museum was almost
like the purest form
of a University museum
because it really
was a museum of MIT.
And so many-- I mean
where I'm working now
with sort of a museum
of the University
but not really because we have
a real disciplinary focus.
Where I'm in an Archaeology
museum right now whereas,
MIT felt like the museum
could be MIT's museum.
And I came in and it felt
sort of multidisciplinary
before that was
sort of fashionable.
Now everyone does that but
it sort of was before that.
We had the historical
collections,
the holography
collections, and I
remember I'm sure, people here.
I remember Don Stidsen,
dear person that we miss.
And Don taking me
around the galleries
and seeing these
holograms and he was--
You know how everyone thinks
they know what a hologram is
and they really don't.
They think it's something
on a ruler you know?
And him very patiently
explaining to me
what actually a hologram was.
And so then I'm in
the holograms and then
suddenly I'm in this exhibit
gallery with Arthur Ganson's
amazing sculptures.
And it just, it almost
felt liberating that like,
wow this is a museum that
could really be so many things.
And so many things
all at the same time.
But also a sense
of, OK we do need
some sort of
focused mission that
thinks about MIT and
particularly the sort of art,
science issue.
Just things that the MIT Museum
could be really, really good
at and so yeah, I think there
was definitely that sort of.
That's often a pressure, but
yeah there was definitely
a feeling of that I think.
John we know that you had
a wife here in Cambridge,
but you were a thriving
professional in the UK.
And what is it that
kind of sucked you
over here, beyond the desire to
maintain good family relations?
Yeah I was actually spending
too much on air miles
or whatever it is, in the
period before I came here.
So there was that,
but I think it's
rather similar I think to
what Jane's just been saying.
There's something
about the potential.
I still think today actually,
the potential of the place
is far greater than the actual.
And that's exciting,
that's something to go for.
I mean, it's not very
inspiring to be in a place
where you think,
well it's pretty much
done everything it can and
it's just a matter of cruising.
Who wants to be in such a place?
I don't know, but not me.
So I was very attracted to that.
It is a feature of
museums in general
I think that they are
in a certain sense
ambiguous as to what
their true character is.
I mean, I'll make an analogy
with academic departments.
If you ask, well, what
exactly is the Department
of Aeronautics and Astronautics?
I mean you don't need to ask
because it's kind of obvious.
But if you ask me what
exactly is the Gardner Museum?
Or what exactly
is the MIT Museum?
It seems as if the question
needs to be answered.
And it's not-- I'm not
original in pointing out
that it's a great
advantage of museums
that they have this ambiguity.
Because they can be molded
and shaped and they can
do all sorts of things.
And I think exploring the
envelope of what you could do
and what might be
interesting and what
might be productive is
part of what makes it a joy
to work in a place like this.
It feels very MIT.
Yes
I've worked in many different
universities so it feels--
sometimes I'm in a
situation where I think,
oh yeah I remember
that happened at Yale.
You know?
And you're trying not
to sound all super
like, oh I worked in all
these great universities,
but MIT is different.
I mean I can safely
say that having worked
in several universities at this
point, but it felt like a place
where you could do all
that and actually it
was encouraged, and
was sort of typical
of the rest of the community.
One thing I will
just comment on, I'm
interested to know
if this was true
also for all of my other
colleagues on the bench
here or whatever on, the panel.
MIT likes to know
what's going on
and there is a whole
administrative structure.
No one has ever
questioned me about why
we're exhibiting this, or
why we chose that topic.
Why are you doing
this thing called
the Enemy, which was all
about international conflict,
or intra-national conflict
actually, as well.
And there was a great liberty
and there is a great liberty
to explore, to experiment.
Was that always true?
I mean, Warren was
that true for you?
Did you feel under pressure
to exhibit certain things
or were people happy for
you to do more or less
whatever you and your
colleagues decided?
If I understand, we just--
we could do anything we
wanted as far as exhibits
because we had no guideline.
We had wonderful collections and
they were building collections
so we took it.
After we developed the
exhibit space in here
we also took over Compton
gallery in the main campus.
So we had a really good
exhibit space there
and then we took over
the Hart Nautical
Collections and gallery.
And so we just had
as wide of variety
as possible from
Charles Woodbury,
who is an American artist who--
early American
impressionist which
has happened in [? Stewart. ?]
He graduated in 1888,
I believe.
And so we could do
whatever we wanted to.
No one told us anything.
And we did have an
advisory committee which
was very supportive
in those early days
and helped us open doors and
find materials and so forth.
Warren, you raised a question.
You shared, Woodbury I
know is one of your loves
but I'm curious with the others
if you have particular objects
or collections or
programs or projects
that you've had a
particular passion
for during your tenure here.
Well I'll share.
I'm very interested in
architecture and design
so I love the
collection which comes out
of the [? Bosar ?] tradition.
We have incredible
drawings and plans
and we had the opportunity when
the architectural collaborative
firm was disbanding to
acquire some of their archive.
And I'm afraid that I was
helping with the dumpster
diving and rescuing
some of those plans.
But they, as it turns
out, they are now
one of, if I'm not mistaken,
one of the most requested
collections because there
are many buildings designed
by the firm TAC, as it's
known, that are being restored
or are being worked on.
And so the documentary
evidence is really important.
So that's one of my
favorite collections.
So that's totally brilliant
Mary because I sort of
liked all the others.
[LAUGHING]
Not that I have anything
against architecture.
But I sort of was like,
oh wow the history,
the hacks, the holograms.
There's a lot of H's in that.
And then the heart.
Oh my God that's four H's.
OK and the Hart
Nautical Collections.
So for me it was just
so exciting to see
all these different things,
many of which I knew zero about.
I remember coming in
and saying to people,
I'm like, she says
modestly, the best director
to have because I know
absolutely nothing about any
of these things.
So I can let you get on all
these amazing curatorial
and collection stuff.
You guys can get on and tell me
what you need and let's think
of a vision and let's--
but I'm not-- I don't know one
end of a yacht from another.
I learned quite a lot about
the history of science and MIT
culture pretty quickly.
But yeah, so it's
hard for me to pick.
For each of us it's different.
Yeah so it's not that I want to
say I don't like architecture,
Gary, I wouldn't say that.
But since Mary said that
I thought I could say it.
I have a different
sort of answer
because I love
lots of the stuff.
But the thing I
really remember being
so pleased about
when I first came
was that this museum
actively collects.
Because I had a
previous experience
in a very large prestigious
museum, which I will not name,
since I'm now going
to criticize it.
Which had such a
large collection
and such a sense
of self-importance
that it had largely
stopped collecting.
And I struggled there to
try and persuade people
that science and technology,
which was what this place did,
hadn't stopped and they ought
to be collecting modern stuff.
And when I came here, as I
think we probably all have done,
I'm guessing with
Warren I'm afraid.
There was a collections
committee and I duly attended.
And every single meeting
their new acquisitions.
And Gary and Debbie and
the rest of the curators
are coming forward and
saying look at this thing.
And we just collect--
sometimes we collect things and
you think, well I suppose so.
But more often it's like, wow!
I remember the day, it was
probably more than 10 years ago
now, Debbie will know.
When we had the opportunity to
collect a whole series of 1950s
and '60s toys,
children's toys that
were made by Claude Shannon, one
of the founders of information
science and technology.
And he made these
things to amuse kids
because he thought it
was boring, I think,
to go buy a store toy when you
could design something better.
And they were better.
I mean they're amazing.
Juggling machines and one of
the world's first chess playing
machines, we have these things
in the collection it's amazing.
Some of them will even
go into the new museum.
That's the thrill for me of
being here that the collections
keep doing this.
Which we have to have a
talk with associate provost
Phillip [? Coorey ?]
and the provost
occasionally about
because it means that we
keep running out of space.
But that's another story.
Well, and the great thing
about the collections committee
and I'm sure this
was Warren's doing,
was having Claude
Brenner as the chair
of that while I was there.
And he was someone that I
dearly loved and was so kind
to me, especially at the
beginning when I was like, I
don't know anything about MIT.
And he sort of would talk with
me and he had so many stories.
And I'm assuming that
you knew him well.
Warren.
And yeah that was--
he was a great person.
And he ran the collections
committee really, really well.
[LAUGHING]
I am curious, you've shared
about your love of collections,
but I have a lot of exhibitions
and programs colleagues here.
I'm wondering if you
might give some--
share some of your most
enjoyable innovations.
I'm thinking of [? FAD ?] and
[? FAST ?] and [? Soap Box, ?]
and of course, we can't--
the Science Festival.
And I'm just wondering if
you might share some stories
about some of your favorite,
or memorable, or challenging
programs and/or exhibitions
that you undertook
during your tenure here.
Well to me, it's amazing
how quickly we got support.
But I would point
out one example,
Al Hill was a vice president
of research, I think.
And he asked us--
they were coming to me,
he had been coming to MIT
as part of the Rad Lab.
And he wanted to do something to
celebrate while there are still
a lot of people
around to celebrate
the history of the Rad Lab.
So he asked us if
we would go down
to outside of
Harrisburg, Pennsylvania
to choose a few photographs
from the collection which
had been taken directly from
MIT and put into federal storage
there.
So we get down there
and found very quickly
that it was a huge
collection, that it was also
due to be just destroyed.
It was in the channel to be
destroyed within the next six
months.
So I call Al Hill and
he called right back
and said, rent a truck and
bring the whole thing back.
So we got the whole history
of, photographic history,
of the Rad Lab just
in one fell swoop.
And that to me, is an
exceedingly important part
of MIT's story.
The Rad Lab and how
it transformed MIT
into a top flight-- not that
it wasn't top flight before,
but a top flight research
University as well as
other things.
But I could go through so
many of the collections that
came in the same way,
came in as a bulk.
Like the hologram
collection for example,
we bought-- we were
sent to an auction
to pick up a few
pieces that Steve
wanted to have here at MIT.
And we ended up getting the
entire collection of holograms
because they wanted to hold
the collection together.
How man holograms
was that, Warren?
How many holograms was that?
Oh I don't know.
We had--
More than two thousand.
Largest collection in the world.
It's by far the best--
Just like that.
We just happened to
get the whole thing.
It's like-- Warren
mentioned the reunions.
And I have to say
that the reunion
event around like the Rad Lab
the whirlwind computer, people,
we did it with
lasers, we've done it
with Lincoln Laboratory,
a number of occasions.
The museum has hosted
really significant events
with pioneers in computing
and radar and the like.
And I'd have to say
Warren, you really
innovated the
reunion event which
often had an accompanying
exhibition, program,
gatherings with people.
It's one of the first most
successful types of programs
this museum had.
They had opportunity for
collecting oral histories,
which are so important
for documenting
whatever the activity is.
But I know Jane, you and
John really also began
to push outward and bring
some new kinds of programs
for families and
other audiences.
And I wonder if you might
tell some stories about those.
So I was thinking
about that because you
had mentioned that last week.
And of course, the
Friday after Thanksgiving
science was brilliant,
I have to say.
Nothing to do with me, but just
really, really great stuff.
That come up with an idea and
you're like, that's the idea.
And now I can't remember
what FAST stands for other
than science and technology.
Family Adventures in
Science and Technology.
Yes and I remember
we started that.
And that was really great but
you know thanks to Arthur.
And then the other thing I
really enjoyed and I remember
because it was just as
you were starting Debbie,
was the exhibition on
artificial intelligence.
It was called-- was it called
robots and beyond then?
Yeah
Yeah, so anyway we
did that because I
remember we were slightly short
staffed, as often was the case.
And so I ended up-- and
this was pretty Debbie,
I ended up doing a lot
about the history of AI,
which I knew nothing about.
But working with Rob
Brooks and other members
of his lab and everything,
which was really fun.
And then spending ages
getting this actually
non-MIT electronic robot
from Bristol, England, which
was on loan to the Smithsonian.
Oh no, it was at the
Smithsonian and we
got this loan and Rob
Brooks just being,
he said to me there's
this thing and I've always
wanted to have it.
Was it the Turpil?
Yes, the [? turtle. ?]
Yeah, so managing and being
so impressed by the
power of the internet
because I was able to track
this down and at the time it
wasn't quite like today.
But anyway, so I loved
that, doing that exhibit.
And it felt like because the
other exhibits had sort of come
in under your tenure and Mary's
with the holograms and Arthur
Ganson sculptures,
but that was something
that we did that
was sort of new.
And then [INAUDIBLE] of
course felt very special.
And just as a credit to
what you're saying Jane,
I mean we didn't finally
manage to stop the Friday
after Thanksgiving chain
reaction until just
a couple of years ago.
I mean, the reason was
that Arthur Ganson
whose idea it probably had been?
It was him and one of our staff.
Was it Marcia?
And Kathy [? Kirsten. ?]
So Marcia and Cassie and
Arthur sort of collectively
came up with it.
Well, by the time
I got here Arthur
was the impresario
who was overseeing
this extraordinary
chain reaction.
And he also made the
final link in the chain.
So he was kind of essential
and each year we'd
say, well would you
mind doing it next year?
Oh all right then.
And then, I might make
next year my last year.
And then you get,
well perhaps one more.
And this went on and on
and on and it went on
because it, you're
absolutely right,
it was just right
for the MIT Museum.
And we would have, in the
latter stages of the program,
we'd have the best part of
1,000 people on bleacher
seats looking at all these
teams making extended chain
reactions in a gymnasium.
I mean just-- and I
hope that tradition
will carry on in new ways, I
must say, in the new museum.
My choice of
exhibition, it's very
difficult but since you
asked, I mean of course
I have a special fondness for
the Cambridge Science Festival.
Not least because I always
suspect that putting up
the genome trail, which
must rank as one of the most
difficult exhibits
I ever oversaw,
along the street between
Kendall and Harvard Square
for the first year
of the festival.
I think it went right
outside Phil Sharp's office.
And he saw this curious
structure on the street
and that's how we came to
get the link with Phil which
has been very important to us.
So I have a double reason
for liking the festival.
But when it comes
to exhibitions I
think I've just got a
shout for this thing
we did recently
called the Enemy.
Which happened in this space
and it was an entirely virtual
reality exhibition.
It was a great achievement
by our exhibitions team
to pull it off.
It was also a collaboration with
the Center for Art, Science,
and Technology [INAUDIBLE] here.
It was very, very hard to
do and very, very memorable
for anybody who actually went
into the exhibition was like,
you've never done
anything like this before.
And to me it was
a special thing.
I did want to point
out one factor that
played a critical role in
building the collections
and getting word out.
We had our first two
students that we,
MIT students that we
hired in the museum.
We had no money to
pay them of course,
but that didn't stop us.
So we-- One was Scott
Ferguson, class of '78 and he
organized a trip, a
tour of every store room
on campus, literally
every store room.
And we worked with
the department
administrative officer
who I knew from my time
in the humanities and we
found phenomenal stuff.
It's just-- we filled the
basement of it here with that.
The other one of those first
to students was David--
I forgot.
David Carp?
David Carp, yes of course.
David had a special knack
for working with film.
And we had taken over a
staggering amount of MIT film
that had come from various
departments and so forth.
And one of the things he did
was to do a film, just as
an example, he did a film
we had in the collection
but had never been
restored or shown.
A film taken in the early
'30s at the at the engineering
camp in Down East
Maine [? Mathias. ?]
And that film was
shown to the class
of '35 and one of the leaders
of the class was watching it
and big tears were rolling down
his eyes because he couldn't
believe that the film from 1931
of him being in East Mathias
even existed.
And this I mean, that shows
you how important and--
that's, I guess that's
why I'm an honorary member
of the class of '35.
But that's another
matter entirely.
I have to tell a
secret story though
that Scott shared with
us a couple of years
ago when he visited.
On this tour, this was when
MIT, everything was keyed
and it's the pre Schlage
system, all Yale locks.
And there was actually
a campus master key.
And Warren, you had
made arrangements
to get hold of one of
these keys to facilitate
this inspection of all these
closets all over the place.
So that they didn't
have to pester
department chairmen and the
like to get into these places.
Scott revealed to me later is
Warren, you gave them this key
and you made them swear six
ways to Sunday that they weren't
going to lose it,
they weren't going
to give it to anyone, that
this was very precious, how
special this was.
And Scott says we
just couldn't tell you
Warren, that we already had
a key because we were part
of the hacking group on campus.
So I'm curious about some of
your challenges that you faced.
Are there some things
that you thought
were going to be super easy
to do and then just turn out
to be nightmarishly difficult?
Or are there some
things that you thought
would be really hard that just
seemed to-- all the pieces
seem to fall into place?
Arthur Ganson was invited to
create a sculpture for
one of these windows here.
And he created a version of,
it's called Margot's Other Cat.
And most of his sculptures,
if you know them,
are pretty intimate,
small scale.
This was an experiment for
him where it was exploded.
And he had all these
gears and this stuff.
I mean it was a stuffed
cat, it was a toy cat
and it was being flung around.
And the animal rights people
in this People's Republic
of Cambridge--
[LAUGHING]
People's Republic of Cambridge
came forward and were outraged.
I forgot about that.
Outraged.
And so what we thought would
be a very effective, at street
level, attractor to the
museum had to be removed.
It was censored.
Do you remember that Jane?
I didn't.
I remember doing-- we
did the whole thing,
but I didn't remember
that, Oh my God.
That's amazing.
Actually it's hard for
me to remember challenges
because Mary dealt with
so much that I'm not
sure I was actually aware of all
the things that were going on.
My biggest challenge
when I came was
that I came with a fixed
idea, as Debbie knows well,
and some other colleagues
who will know too,
I was going to move this
museum into the Metropolitan
warehouse.
And it was going
to take five years.
But if you look at the first
strategic plan that we oversaw,
in my time, that was
the lead message,
by the end of this plan will
be in the metro warehouse.
If that had been done, we'd
have been in the metro warehouse
in 2010.
And it probably is obvious to
you all that we didn't do that.
And the reason was
that was much harder
to pull off than I realized.
And it was impossible, in fact.
I do remember seeing that
strategic plan and thinking,
hmm.
[LAUGHING]
You never told me.
No I didn't, because
I don't do that.
I just think, good luck.
But yes, I remember
because Harvey
was yeah-- he had worked so
hard to try make that happen.
But we actually pulled
back from doing it
and I'm quite struck
that you asked
two questions if I remember.
One was a challenge, something
you thought would be easy
and was hard, that was the one.
And the other thing,
what you thought
would be hard turned out to be
easy was actually, in a sense,
getting permission
to go and start
the new museum in Kendall.
Because we had given
up, in my time,
the idea of going
into a new place.
And then suddenly this
opportunity sprang up.
And I won't try and
go into the details,
but suddenly there
was an opportunity
you never thought was there.
So that would be the
flip side of the coin.
I have one that I thought
was going to be difficult
and then turned easy which
was, around the hacks
and the collection of hacks.
And I arrived and I remember
I got a call from someone,
actually I don't remember
the person's name,
but I think he was
in material science.
Anyway, the student newspaper,
which of course I've
now forgotten the
name of, The Tech
had done an article
about me arriving.
And at some point
I had honestly said
something that led
them to believe
that I was going to take
the police car off display.
So the article, the
tenor of the article
was, who the hell does
this woman think she is?
She doesn't understand MIT.
How could she even
conceive of it?
Which of course, I had
no such conception.
Anyway, so I he left a
message, I called him back
and we had a great
conversation and I
wish I could remember who it was
because then we became friends.
But I remember thinking
actually inside, oh my God
how am I going to learn
about this hack collection
and how are we going to
look after it and whatever.
And then meeting,
well of course Don
was around, sorry to
keep mentioning him,
but around who sort
of was calming me
down about how, Yes we would
be able to conserve them.
Because of course, I'm looking
at these things thinking,
how are we going
to conserve them?
How are they still going
to be around in 100 years?
Except for the donuts,
which I don't think ever
needed conserving because
they just were still exactly
the same 12 years
after whatever.
Anyway the donuts never
needed to be replaced.
They were Dunkin' Donuts.
They were Dunkin'
Donuts and I was
like never eat Duncan--
do like 12 years later,
they still look
exactly the same?
What is it that they have?
But then meeting Terry
and just suddenly becoming
aware that there was this whole
community around the hacks that
were going to help
me get to grips.
And suddenly I thought
like I totally get this.
There are so many
people around to help.
So that was
something that caused
me a little inner sort of angst
and then soon became clear
that everyone at
MIT loved the hacks.
And so they were going to really
be helpful about doing it.
So that was something that--
Speaking of humorous
fun, Warren you
started something
the Ig Nobel awards.
And they attracted quite
a bit of attention.
And my favorite is the year
that they were sponsored by you
and Cathy and others
invented Kelvin,
the unisex fragrance that made
all wearers absolutely cool.
And there were
shirts and t-shirts
about Kelvin and the fragrance,
but tell maybe people
about the Ig Nobel awards.
Many of you have heard
about them at Harvard
but didn't know
that they actually
originated here at the museum.
We were approached by
a student, if we've
answered in sponsoring it.
And it sounded like a great
idea so we reserved Kresge,
and we did I think four
or five years of it
before it moved up the
street to the other school
here in Cambridge.
But at any rate, it was a very
unusual event to say the least.
I will say in theory,
Kelvin was sold in the shop.
And we haven't
talked about the shop
but I know that
the shop has been
really important to all four of
your tenure here at the museum.
And I wondered if you have
some memories of getting it--
how did that get started?
And the famous
catalog and then Jane,
you had to-- we had a shop,
then we didn't have a shop,
then we had a shop.
Like how did this come to be?
I do vaguely remember there
had been a previous large store
that I never saw which
hadn't done so well.
I recall that.
Let's just pass discreetly
over that by saying--
But when I started
we had a tiny store
and it was a shelf,
or maybe two shelves,
linked to what was then the
main entrance to this museum
on the second floor.
And it was sort of under
where the admissions staff
person stood.
And there might have been
20 different items for sale.
And the amazing
thing was, I still
remember that tiny store,
not even really a store
just a couple of shelves,
apparently it was turning over,
I think, the figure in my
head is $60,000 a year.
So I mean, that's not much for
a store, but on the other hand,
there's not much
by way of a store.
So it's like, well, there
could be something here.
And so that's why when we opened
this floor, which was in 2007,
we decided to take a gamble
and bring the store down
to the ground floor where
it absolutely thrived.
Well it had a street presence
which it never had before.
One of the interesting things
about the catalog though,
is that occurs at
precisely the moment
that the world is going digital.
And I'm looking at David Nunez
here and thinking a little bit
maybe to ask you a little
bit about our digital museum.
I realize-- who started?
Who had the first website?
And when did we--?
Mary, you were part of getting
the very first experiments
with getting collections online.
And Jane, you got a
digitizing holography.
[INAUDIBLE] Richard's
database that.
Yes, I remember that.
But actually we did,
Cara Schneiderman,
who was our registrar and
collections manager, who's
now the director of
collections at Jane's museum,
started the museum
website in the mid 1990's
when almost nobody
had a website.
And she did a
fabulous job with it.
And then really focused on
the Edgerton collection,
which we had funding to digitize
and make available online.
So that's kind of I
would say the nucleus
or the starter collection
for our digital collections.
I'm interested in a question
about people and audience
here for the museum.
And each of you, you've
spoken about alumni
and we've talked about
people in public.
But who do you think of
when you first came here,
what was the target audience?
And how then have
you viewed it as--
what have been the
opportunities to expand
that audience over time?
I think there's a duality.
The MIT community is a
very important audience
but then we as a museum we want
to serve the greater community
too.
So I think that figuring
out that mission
and how to serve the
MIT community and then
at the same time
the general public.
I'll just say that as a starter.
Yeah, no, I think that's right.
It felt like it was
sort of everybody.
Which is the same as
saying nobody but yeah,
I definitely when I came
in felt there was that MIT
community without question.
The Cambridge
community and then sort
of people who were coming
to find out about MIT.
I mean MIT has this sort
of incredible reputation
across the world.
And so there would be
this sense in which
the museum was the place to
sort of present MIT in all its--
all the facets.
And so yeah, I would say
that's how I sort of divided it
in my head really.
I don't know if
that's changed a lot.
I think it is true, just
reflecting on my time,
that when I came
I think I wanted
us to give a real emphasis
to audiences outside MIT.
And the way I used
to put it, so I
must have believed
this because I
can remember this little spiel.
And the spiel was, MIT folks
we really want you on the stage
more than we want
you in the audience.
And to me that's
always been the case.
The MIT faculty and students
are the single most appealing
exhibits that the MIT
Museum will ever have.
And my colleagues have
heard me say this before,
if we have an MIT research
student playing with something
on the exhibition floor it
will be the star attraction,
whatever they're doing.
When we opened this ground
floor, Gary will remember,
we had an experimental
wheel assembly
that had been made as part
of the city car project
by folks in the Media Lab.
And of course it was
an experimental car.
So guess what?
The working wheel assembly
worked for about 12 hours.
And then it stopped.
And of course it was a
research student project
so after a time, and
whenever they felt like it,
some students turned up.
They didn't think about
whether there was any audience,
they just came.
A bunch of people in jeans and
t-shirts and laptops and they
started over there
fiddling with this thing
to try and make it work.
And before long, the entire,
because the museum was open,
the entire audience
on the ground floor
had deserted all
the other exhibits
and they were all crowded around
these research students who
were just simply
playing with a laptop
and doing something, who knows.
It's always been that
way in my experience.
So I've always felt that our
greatest asset is the MIT
community, but we
want to get them
in front of audiences
who don't get a chance
to meet them every day.
So that was what I
was trying to do,
to swivel our attention as
far as visitors are concerned
but to do it with the
whole of MIT behind us.
I'm thinking as we come
to the end of this panel,
that I was remembering
my first day of work.
And Jane you called
me into your office
to discuss your plans for me.
And they included a
pair of exhibitions.
One of them was the
aforementioned robotics
and AI exhibit.
Another was an exhibit,
and you said to me
at the time I've
always remembered this,
robots are to science
museums, what dinosaurs
are to natural history museums.
We must do an exhibit and
we come by it honestly here.
But then you said,
nobody really knows
what the MIT Museum
has to offer in terms
of exhibitions and programs.
But to the extent they
expect anything or have
any conception, it's that
this will be a place that they
can learn something about MIT.
Its history, its achievements,
its challenges, and why MIT
matters.
And I thought that might
be a great question
to pose to you a little bit
about why you think MIT still
needs a museum.
And we're about to--
we're at a real inflection
point in our history.
We're going to move into
extraordinarily a new facility.
We have an amazing
new team of people
here on board to
make that transition
and I'm really
wondering if you might
share with us some of your
thoughts about the museum.
What makes it distinctive?
Why it's valuable?
And what you hope
maybe for the future.
I'm really interested to
hear what you think John.
I mean to me it seems so
exciting to be a real gateway.
I mean I think we've always
seen the museum as a gateway
into MIT but now it's sort of
physically literal, as well
as sort of in terms
of what we're doing.
And you know, I'm
tempted to say honestly
that if MIT didn't
have the museum,
it would have to reinvent it.
And so I see it more,
not more, but I see it
partly in terms of what the
Institute actually needs.
So MIT is, as we all
know, it's a place devoted
to knowledge in pursuit
of public service
and in pursuit of
the public good.
If you look at the
mission statement for MIT
that's what it's about.
And I think we
know enough to know
that however smart
a group of people
is, they can't do
that successfully
if they're doing it in a
closed room on their own.
They're not going to be able
to get the changes they want
and make the world
a better place.
You need to engage the
wider community in that.
I just think at MIT's work
is so important that it's
very important that a
wider community be engaged
in what the Institute is doing.
And of course, we're not the
only people at MIT who do that.
But I do think this is a focus
in the Institute for that
kind of engagement.
And that's I think
why it's so important.
I just think it's where we
are in the 21st century,
we know there's a lot of
questioning of expertise.
There's a lot of questioning
of science in recent years,
in ways that some of us
might never have imagined.
And if we're going to
address those issues
we've got to be out there.
And what better place to
be out there from than MIT.
Well I hope you
all might join me
in thanking our panelists for
sharing some of their memories
and thoughts.
We're going to have an
opportunity to share stories
with each other.
In a few moments
our caterers are
going to bring in
treats for all of us.
But thank you Warren,
Mary, John, and Jane.
[LAUGHING]
This woman had the best
application letter.
I've hired many people.
It started, dear, I don't know
whoever, search committee,
as I sit in my house that
is about 2 and 1/2 million,
she had the exact number,
smoots from the MIT
Museum.
That was the first sentence
and I was like, OK,
I think this is who we need.
So yes, I'm the woman that
hired you, my name is Jane.
[LAUGHING]
I got out of order
but anyway I want
to thank you all, both
for today, but also
for 50 years of amazing
service to this museum.
[APPLAUSE]